[Musique]
nous était gouvernement depuis le début
de cette crise c'est tout à fait tout à
fait stupéfiant si aujourd'hui il y à
une distribution de masques dans les
territoires c'est parce que les
collectivités ont fait ce que l'état ce
que le gouvernement a été un foutu de
faire donc c'est bien beau de courir
après la locomotive mais en l'occurrence
il ya eu une faute grave depuis le début
la gestion de cette crise sur des
masques dont on nous a dit qu'il n'était
pas utile et qui ne sont jamais arrivées
lorsque c'était nécessaire
alors on les aura finalement quand ce
sera quasiment trop tard et donc une
seule question c'est est-ce que nous
avons confiance est-ce que j'ai
confiance en ce gouvernement
la réponse c'est non faut vraiment faire
confiance aux territoires et aujourd'hui
il ya des décisions qui sont encore trop
dans les bureaux parisiens il faut faire
confiance à un maximum dans les
territoires je constate l'inefficacité
de l'état et c'est l'apprentissage de
ces crimes
moi ce que je reproche au gouvernement
quand je disais que le gouvernement n'a
eu qu'une stratégie de la cloche c'est à
dire oui défensive
je pense qu'on n'a pas cassé les reins
de l'épidémie pour casser les reins
d'épidémie il faut casser la chaîne de
contamination et on casse la chaîne de
contamination en traçant testant et en
traçant malgré contact nous avons été
confinée pendant deux mois les efforts
ont été énormes visible pour les pour
les français aujourd'hui la chaîne de
contamination est cassé la maladie est
contrôlé il faut absolument faire
attention à ce qu'elles ne ça ne
repartent pas et donc il faut vivre avec
un certain nombre de mesures de contrôle
sanitaire mais il faut que notre
économie reparte il faut que que nous
ayons à l'école que nous que le tourisme
ne fonctionne que la vie reprenne tout
simplement via trois éléments majeurs
pour pouvoir dès confiner la france
c'est la reprise de l'école la relance
économique mais aussi la reprise des
transports
et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que dans ces
trois domaines et dans les plans qui
nous ont été présentés les grandes
lignes des grands principes qui sont
mais ensuite les détails sont pas
forcément les plus clair puisqu'il ya eu
beaucoup de dessous pour mater des
contradictions
nous sommes en train de décrocher au
plan économique plus fortement que tous
nos autres partenaires plus fortement
plus lourdement que tous les autres pays
en chute de 6% de croissance
le pl objectif est que le pays revienne
au travail moi je suis partisan d'un
allégement massif des charges sociales
parce que là il faut ce qu'on appelle en
économie un choc d'offre
il faut absolument accompagner les
entreprises le cot le confinement pose
un tas de sujets majeurs économique
on va se retrouver avec 5 ou 10 millions
de chômeurs de santé publique parce
qu'il ya des gens qui souffrent dans
leur santé du confinement de liberté on
entrave d'état de libertés publiques
donc le confinement c'est vraiment un
pis-aller si on peut le relever dans
certaines régions il faut lui
[Musique]